being a d-class for the scp foundation
is a lot like playing russian roulette
one day you could be assigned to a
tickle fight with a friendly blob of
slime
and next you're getting your femurs
broken to lure a sadistic old man
back into his containment chamber so
when d
9781 was told to simply sit in an
interrogation room and wait
he really didn't know what to think but
the last thing he probably expected to
see
was when the door behind him creaked
open was for a well-dressed stranger to
step
in this man wasn't like any member of
foundation staff the d-class had ever
seen
he was a short caucasian man with a
receding hairline
and a neat black mustache instead of the
standard lab coat and shirt normally
seen around the facility
this man wore a black waistcoat a pair
of white gloves
and a wry smile that betrayed a sinister
intent
he looked like a butler and not just any
butler but the quintessential
butler if you were asked to doodle a
cartoon butler
this would be the man you drew the
d-class almost laughed in sheer
confusion
he had no idea that in a mere moment he
would be dead
now what's the deal jeeves he asked with
a mocking half smile
but he didn't get to hear a response the
butler approached at frightening speeds
the d-class in his last moments on earth
saw the glint of something metallic
under the overhead lights moving too
fast for him to see what it was
and then felt a sharp pain across his
throat the butler was standing beside
him now
still with that rye little smile the
d-class could see now that the butler
was carrying a small buck knife
dripping with red just as he was piecing
together what had happened to him
the d-class collapsed onto the table he
was sitting at his throat
expertly slit his grisly task completed
the butler gave a polite nod and exited
the room
smiling at the foundation guard standing
outside who is this man
why is he dressed like this and most
importantly
why is he allowed to murder d-class
personnel on foundation grounds without
consequence
we can answer that first question right
now because this
isn't a man at all he's the anomalous
product of scp-662
also known as the butler's handbell
first we need to go back to the
beginning
and see how this anomalous object first
fell into the hands of the scp
foundation
like a lot of anomalous objects now
under the care of the foundation
its true origins remain mysterious and
it spent
quite some time underground we mean that
literally
by the way it was buried with its last
owner a man whose name has since been
redacted from foundation
files clutched in this unknown man's
skeletal hand
it was extremely likely that the bell
might never have been seen again
but then a petty thief and grave rover
by the name of george dixon came along
and dug up the grave
a simple greedy act that has changed a
number of people's lives
forever not knowing the true value of
what he held
mr dixon made his way to a pawn shop for
his payday
there the store owner made the mistake
of lifting up
and ringing the bell as if on cue he
heard footsteps approaching behind him
the store owner turned and gasped he saw
a complete stranger emerging from the
stockroom behind him
he was a short well-dressed man smiling
as he advanced towards him
the proprietor of the pawn shop didn't
know who this guy with the strange
outfit was
but he assumed he was an accomplice of
the man in his store and that the two
were trying to rob him
he grabbed a shotgun from underneath his
counter turned to the butler and blasted
him in the chest with both barrels
the butler fell back dead and george
dixon fled the scene in a blind panic
contrary to what the owner may have
believed nothing that happened here
had been planned dixon was just as
surprised as he was to see this
mysterious butler emerge from the
stockroom
so what had just happened the pawn shop
owner reported the incident to the
authorities and the butler's body was
taken to the local morgue
while the silver bell ended up in a
police evidence locker
later that same night things went from a
strange bungled robbery
to a full-on anomaly attracting the
attention
of the scp foundation first the butler's
body disappeared from the morgue the
second the mortician took her eyes off
of it
and then reappeared now alive in the
police storage locker
why because an unwitting sergeant just
so happened to ring the little silver
bell
agent bradford of the scp foundation was
promptly on the scene
he pretended to be an fbi agent and
escorted the butler off the premises
claiming that this was a notorious
escape artist who was wanted for federal
crimes in several
states things didn't go as bradford
planned though
when he discovered that the butler had
disappeared from his handcuffs when no
one was looking
agent bradford theorized that this had
something to do with the bell
and he confiscated it for testing later
when he rang the bell
inside an scp containment facility the
butler turned up once more
he introduced himself as mr deeds and
said that he would happily perform
any service that agent bradford required
despite being offered the phenomenal
power of a seemingly magical butler
bradford politely refused the offer and
instead handed the bell over to his
superiors
but don't worry agent bradford wasn't
left completely empty-handed
and was given the esteemed scp
foundation pat on the back award
for performing such a professional and
selfless act
in service of the foundation the
superior who ended up with the bell
however wouldn't have quite the same
level of professionalism
but more on that later the bell
cataloged as scp-662
was small and made of pure silver with
no obvious anomalous elements at face
value
it was a mere four centimeters tall and
two centimeters wide
with a small inscription reading forever
mine
sjw researchers studying the bell also
noted that it lacked its ringer
but whenever the bell was wrong a chime
would still
sound from somewhere in the room to
signal the arrival of mr deeds
the anomalous butler the object was
classified as
safe and was kept in high value storage
locker 23c
between uses for experiments it's an
extremely low maintenance anomaly
with the only real requirement being a
regular polish to keep the silver from
tarnishing over time
but what of mr deeds the mysterious
butler summoned every time someone rings
as cp 662 the foundation needed to find
out more
so he was placed under the watchful eye
of foundation researcher dr mirth
who performed the first interview with
mr deeds
as you can probably expect from such a
classy servant mr deeds was unfailingly
polite during the interview
he always addressed dr mirth as sir and
was extremely accommodating
within reason mr deed's true name
birthplace and date of birth were still
a mystery to him
he could only vaguely remember that he
was of english ancestry
and that during the time of his
childhood the horse and buggy were the
most popular form of transport
when asked about personal details or his
past mr deeds would often appear to
become distressed before apologizing for
his inability to remember the details
the most important piece of information
that dr mirth obtained early on in the
interview
was the primary function of mr deeds he
was an entity that quite literally
lived to serve like a genie being
summoned from his lamp
mr deeds would try to perform any task
that the summoner gave him
whether it was cooking dinner or robbing
banks
there were certain limits to these
powers though and these limits were what
dr
mirth needed to discover dr mirth first
asked for a glass of iced tea from mr
deeds
the butler happily obliged and left the
room walking down the hallway
while attending agents kept their eyes
on him mr deeds continued to merely walk
however the second they looked away the
cameras observing him malfunctioned
deeds briefly disappeared and then
returned with a tray of iced tea dr
mirth remarked that it was perhaps the
best iced tea he'd ever tasted
mr deeds couldn't recall how the tea was
made though or how he obtained it
dr mirth next asked for a bar of gold at
99.98
purity and mr deeds delivered almost the
exact level of purity dr mirth
asked for from this he deduced that mr
deeds can only perform his teleportation
and manifestation abilities when he's
out of people's direct lines of sight
he soon discovered that certain requests
were off the table though
dr mirth asked for mr deeds to fetch him
a blue 1963 corvette convertible
mr deeds did not immediately procure the
car instead telling the doctor that such
a thing was impossible
because there were too many impractical
steps involved in getting the vehicle
dr mirth was disappointed by this since
he really wanted that car
it seemed though as mr deeds powers
while enhanced by teleportation and the
ability to manifest simple objects
are limited by things that a mostly
normal and very persistent person could
conceivably do
for example on dr murth's orders mr
deeds politely declined to assassinate
an insurgent leader in the middle east
seeing as he was too well-guarded and
very far away
however when given the command he was
more than willing to head into the next
room and murder a member of d-class with
a knife
dr mirth was interested in getting a
closer look at what was going on with mr
deeds biology and so asked him to slit
his own throat with the same knife he
used to murder the d-class
mr deeds politely obliged commenting
before he did to dr mirth that had been
an absolute pleasure
serving him the body was kept within an
agent's line of sight at all time
until the autopsy could be performed
just to make sure it didn't disappear
the autopsy showed that there was
nothing inherently anomalous about the
physiology of mr deeds
and he would appear as good as new the
next time the bell rang
things took an even stranger turn after
that though
despite it appearing like the foundation
now knew everything they needed to know
about mr deeds and the scp-662 bell
dr mirth insisted on performing further
studies into what exactly mr deeds was
capable of
for example he requested a deep tissue
massage
and found that it completely cured his
back pain dr mirth also asked mr deeds
to clean his car
and found that it was cleaned to a truly
impeccable standard
during his tenure as the lead researcher
on the 662 project
he also asked to receive a haircut from
mr deeds and found out that while mr
deeds excelled at many tasks
he made a pretty bad barber he was great
at laundry though
dr mirth was eventually removed from 662
duty by the o5 council
once it became clear his research had
just become an excuse for mr deeds to do
errands and chores for him
of course mr deeds had no complaints
either way
whether it's serving up delicious tea
cleaning a certain selfish researcher's
home
or murdering a d-class personnel with a
buck knife
one thing cannot be denied mr deeds
is one hell of a butler now go watch
scp-066 eric's toy
and scp-4999 someone to watch over us
tale for more of the best stories
straight from the scp foundation